so can we uh
give an overview of how is way more born
how's the google self-driving car
project born what's the what is the
mission
what is the hope what is it is the
engineering kind of uh set of milestones
that it seeks to accomplish there's a
lot of questions in there
uh yeah i think you're right it kind of
the
urban challenge and the upper and
previous double grand challenges i can
let i think to a very large you know
degree to that next step and you know
larry and sergey um
uh larry page and you know sergey brin
uh uh google hunter scores
uh saw that competition and believed in
the technology
so now the google self-driving car
project was born
you know at that time and we started in
2009 it was a
pretty small group of us about a dozen
people who came together
to to work on on this project at google
at that time we saw an
you know that incredible early result
in the darpa urban challenge i think
we're all incredibly excited
about where we got to and we believed in
the future of the technology but we
still had a very
rudimentary understanding of the problem
space so
the first goal of this project in 2009
was to really
better understand what we're up against
and you know with that
goal in mind when we started the project
we created a few milestones for
ourselves
that maximized learnings
well the two milestones were you know
one was to drive a hundred thousand
miles
in autonomous mode which was at that
time you know orders of magnitude that
uh more than anybody has ever done and
the second milestone was to drive
10 routes uh each one was 100 miles long
they were specifically chosen to become
extra spicy you know extra complicated
and
sample the full complexity of the
that that domain
and you had to drive each one from
beginning to end
with no intervention no human
intervention so you'd get to the
beginning of the course
uh you would you press the the button
that include engage in autonomy
and you had to you know go for 100 miles
you know beginning to end
with no interventions um and it sampled
again the full complexity of driving
conditions some
uh where on freeways we had one route
that went all through all the freeways
and all the
bridges in the bay area you know we had
some that went around lake tahoe
and kind of mountainous roads we had
some that drove through
dense urban um environments like in
downtown palo alto
and through san francisco so it was
incredibly
uh interesting uh to work on
and it uh it took us
just under two years about a year and a
half a little bit more
to finish both of these milestones and
in that process
uh you know hey it was an incredible
amount of fun probably the most
fun i had in my professional career and
because you're just learning so much you
are you know the goal here is to learn
and prototype you're not yet starting to
build a production system right so you
just
you were you know this is when you're
kind of you know working 24 7 and you're
hacking things together and you also
don't know
how hard this is i mean it's the point
like
so i mean that's an ambitious if i put
myself in that mindset even still
that's a really ambitious set of goals
like just those two
picking it's picking 10 different
difficult spicy challenges
and then having zero interventions so
like not saying gradually we're going to
like you know over a period of 10 years
we're going to have a bunch of roots and
gradually reduce the number of
interventions
you know that literally says like by but
as soon as possible we want to have zero
and on hard roads so like to me if i was
facing that
it's unclear that whether that takes two
years or whether that takes 20 years
i i guess that speaks to a really big
difference between doing something once
and having a prototype where you are
going after
you know learning about the problem
versus how you go about engineering a
product
that you know where you look at uh you
know you
properly do evaluation you look at
metrics you you know drive down and
you're confident that you can do that
and i guess that's the you know why it
took a dozen people
uh you know 16 months or a little bit
more than that
uh back in 2009 and 2010
and with the technology of you know the
more than a decade ago
uh that amount of time to achieve that
milestone
of 10 routes 100 miles each and no
interventions
uh and you know it
took us a little bit longer to get to
you know a full driverless product
that customers use that's another really
important moment is there's some
memories of uh technical lessons or just
one like what did you learn about the
problem of driving from that experience
i mean we could we can now talk about
like what you learned from
modern day waymo but i feel like you may
have learned some profound things
in those early days even more so
because it feels like what waymo is now
is to trying to
you know how to do scale how to make
sure you create a product how to make
sure is like safety and all those things
which is
all fascinating challenges but like you
were facing the more fundamental
philosophical problem of driving in
those early days like
what the hell is driving as an
autonomous
or maybe i'm again romanticizing it but
is it
is there uh is there some valuable
lessons you picked up over there
at those two years uh a ton
the most important one is probably that
we believe that it's doable and we've
gotten
uh far enough into the problem that uh
you know
we had a i think only a glimpse of the
true complexity
uh of the the the domain
yeah it's a little bit like you know
climbing a mountain where you kind of
you know see the next
peak and you think that's kind of the
summit but then you get to that and you
kind of see that that this is just
the start of the journey but we've tried
we've sampled enough of the problem
space
and we've made enough rapid uh success
even you know with technology of
2009-2010
that it gave us confidence to then you
know pursue this
as a real product so okay
so the next step you mentioned the the
milestones
that you had in the in those two years
what are the
next milestones that then led to the
creation of waymo and beyond
now it uh it was a really interesting
journey and
waymo came a little bit later uh
then you know we completed those
milestones in 2010
that was the pivot when we decided to
focus
on actually building a product yeah
using this technology
uh the initial couple years after that
we were focused
on a freeway you know what you would
call a driver assist
uh maybe on all three driver assist
program then around 2013 we've learned
enough uh about the space and the
thought
more deeply about you know the
product that we wanted to build that we
pivoted we pivoted towards
of this vision of you know building a
driver
and deploying it fully driverless
vehicles without a person and that
that's the path that we've been
on since then and uh very it was exactly
the right decision for us
so there was a moment where you're also
considered like what is the right
trajectory here
what is the right role of automation in
the in the task of driving there's still
it wasn't from the early days obviously
you want to go fully autonomous
from the early days was not i think it
was in 20 around 2013 maybe
uh that we've that became very clear
and we made that pivot and it also
became very clear uh and
that it's either the way you go building
a driver
assist system is you know fundamentally
different from how you go building a
fully driverless vehicle so you know
we've
uh pivoted uh towards the ladder
and that's what we've been working on
ever since and
so that was around 2013 then
their sequence of really meaningful for
us really important
uh defining milestones since then in
2015 we
had our first actually the world's first
fully driverless uh trade
on uh public roads it was in a custom
build vehicle that we had
we must have seen those we called them
the firefly that you know funny looking
marshmallow looking thing
um and we uh put uh
a passenger uh his name was steve mann a
great
friend of our project from the early
days uh the the man happens to be
uh blind so we put him in that vehicle
the car had no steering wheel no pedals
it was an uncontrolled environment
um you know no you know lead or chase
cars no police escorts um
and uh you know we did that trip a few
times in austin texas
so that was a really big milestone but
that was in austin yeah cool
okay yeah um and you know we only but at
that time we're only
it took a tremendous amount of
engineering it took a tremendous amount
of validation
uh to get to that point uh but you know
we
only did it a few times right we only
did that it was a fixed route
it was not kind of a controlled
environment but it was a fixed route and
we only did a few times
uh then uh in
uh 2016 uh end of 2016 beginning of 2017
is uh when we founded waymo uh the
company that's when
we kind of that was the next phase of
the project where i wanted
we believed in kind of the commercial uh
vision of this technology
and it made sense to create an
independent entity you know within that
alphabet umbrella to pursue this product
um at scale uh beyond that in 2017 later
in 2017
was another really a huge
step for us really big milestone where
we started it was october
of 2017 where when we
started regular driverless
operations on public roads that first
day of operations we drove
uh in one day and that first day 100
miles and
you know driverless fashion and then
we've the most the most important thing
about that milestone was not that you
know 100 miles in one day
but that it was the start of kind of
regular ongoing
driverless operations can we say
driverless it means no driver
that's exactly right so on that first
day we actually hit a mix and
up uh in some uh we didn't want to like
you know be on youtube on twitter that
same day so in
uh and many of the rides we had somebody
in the driver's seat yeah but they could
not disengage like the car okay it's not
disengaged
but actually on that first day uh some
of the
miles were driven and just completely
empty driver's seat
you